yeah just thank you everyone who is the
I'm so honored to be in this room with
so amazing people and give yourself an
applause this award is for all those
millions of people young people around
the world who together make up a
movement called Friday's for future all
these fearless youth fighting for their
future a future they should be able to
take for granted but as as looks now
they cannot with our business as usual
we are currently on track for a world
that could displace billions of people
from their homes taking away even the
most basic living conditions from
countless of people making areas of the
world uninhabitable for humans or
possibly here the facts that this will
create huge conflicts and unspoken
sufferings is far from Secrets and yet
the link between the climate and
ecological emergency and mass migration
famine violations of human rights and
war is still not clear to many people
the changes and the politics required to
take on this crisis simply doesn't exist
today that is why every single one of us
must push from every possible angle to
hold
those responsible accountable and to
make the people in power act and to take
the measures required we who together
are the movement Fridays for future we
are fighting for our lives but not only
that we are also fighting for our future
children and grandchildren for future
generations for every single living
being on earth whose biosphere we share
whose biosphere we are stealing whose
biosphere we are ruining we are fighting
for everyone for you for the people
living in areas in the world that are
already suffering the consequences from
the first stages of the climate and
ecological emergency
people who breathe toxic air who drink
contaminated water who have to flee
their homes because of climate and
environmental related disasters
indigenous communities whose lands and
waters are being destroyed people whose
food and water supply is being
threatened by environmental related
catastrophes stronger and more frequent
droughts rainfalls storms or melting
glaciers whole nations are now literally
being left in ruins or disappearing
underneath rising sea levels
people are dying and yet so many of us
keep looking away the world has never
seen a threat to human rights of this
scope so said the UN right Steve
Michelle Bachelet
during recently during un UN Human
Rights Council in Geneva referring to
the climate crisis she said the
economies of all nations the
institutional political social and
cultural fabric of every state and the
rights of all your people and future
generations will be impacted this is
exactly the clarity we need now from
governments and the people in power
right now the world's emissions of
greenhouse gases keep rising rapidly the
destruction of natural habitats are
continuing at horrendous speed despite
all the beautiful words and promises
from our leaders we are still moving in
the wrong direction with unimaginable
pace it may seem impossible to pull the
emergency brake and yet that is what we
have to do but right now I think there
is an awakening going on even though it
is slow the pace is picking up and the
debates is shifting this is thanks to a
lot of different reasons but it is a lot
because because of countless of
activists and especially young activists
activism works
[Applause]
so what I'm telling you to do now is to
act because no one is too small to make
a difference I'm urging all of you to
take part in the global climate strikes
on September 20th and 27th
and just one last thing see you on the
streets
[Applause]